[Music]
dove cameron is out to steal your girl
in the music video for boyfriend
it's nice to feel like you have a song
that you really back but don't be fooled
by the title of her hit single i don't
need to tell you twice all the ways
if i could give you some advice i would
leave
tonight this new banger is the singer's
first queer anthem following dove coming
out as bisexual in 2020. i was shocked
with how many people were shocked the
video kicks off with dove making her way
through a grungy nightclub then locking
eyes with a woman across the dance floor
[Music]
the chemistry is instant with her lucky
lady played by model charlene lefevre
[Music]
and their electric connection takes off
from there leading to these steamy
makeouts
[Music]
yep dove presents a solid case for
herself as the better love interest and
there's no debate after the song's final
lyric
i could be such a gentleman
[Music]
two years after coming out dove says
being authentic is more important than
ever you are not here to please anybody
but yourself and at the end of the day
if you go to sleep and you're like
today
i represented myself in a way that made
me feel so seen by me
that's all that matters
and just last week dove was telling ety
boyfriend is now a personal favorite
how much do you love that song you know
it's funny i actually do still really
love it and it's really fun because i
didn't my boyfriend that long ago and
it's still very like relevant to my life
and my sounds and sonically very
romanced by it who's boyfriend about
girl
imagine if i just spell it out right now
um no i'll never reveal it i'll never
reveal it no
okay so no answer on that end but she
did confirm there's more jams on the
horizon could we get new music from you
soon even more
right now
yeah let me just release it right now um
yeah i'm definitely thinking might i
think i have my next single all lined up
and
teed up and yeah i'm really excited to
share everything now that i feel like
i've really like found myself in my
sound so
i'll call you first that has to feel
good i love what you just said that has
to feel good to be like i'm performing
as myself this is what i want to put out
there yeah i think it was something that
like i described like looking for your
sound as like feeling around in the dark
for like something warm you're like i
don't know where i'm going or what i'm
looking for but i'll know when i find it
and so now that i feel like i've found
it it feels very um like obvious and
easy so almost looking back it's like
how could i not have known that but it's
really i i i don't think i ever knew i
was going to be able to be so myself
in my line of work so it's very exciting
[Music]